[Musik]
[Applaus]
für morgen neue block 94 mit programme
ihr fragt euch jetzt mit sicherheit halo
klar ich hoffe der zu der ehre das
bräuchte weil wir blogger buchautor
hatte unser haus zu geklingelt und
gedacht uns erst mal so hell wie kommt
man allerdings wurden uns 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
war die neue luca pizza drei zugesendet
sie mir sind da nicht eventuell finale
die neue arbeits mindest proben von der
neuen look und die werden wir nachher
zusammen probieren
[Musik]
die reiten geschwind ich bin tot
angerückt laudatio heißt du nicht
[Musik]
ja ich weiß ich sollte vom sport juli
geht dir alter wie weit ich einfach mit
dieser kamera zoomen kann wow muffins
aller das heutige video nicht von
muffins handeln sondern genau und
zwiebeln das ist luca besser drei von
hinten und da sehen wir schon das erste
was anders sein will hat bei der pizza 2
und zwar ist der teig nicht spaß also
der tag ist nicht mit aktivkohle mit
drin
ein stinknormaler normaler hallo marco
pizzateig
market westhofen bei 150 grad komplett
vorhalten dass genau betriebsarten ober
unterhitze oder grad okay okay wir
vorbereitet während der ofen vorheizen
lassen wir die pizza schon mal so ein
bisschen an tauen
das ist immer ganz wichtig weil die
pizza noch besser schmeckt das gemacht
weil die polizei münster 2 habe ich bis
die hitze bringt dich raus gekommen dass
also bis kurz vorher komplett geheim
gehalten was es für eine pizza sein
gehen und auch letztes jahr mit der
aktivkohle und dass der teig schwarz ist
das habe ich erst ein paar tage vorher
gesagt hatte ich bei dem luca pizza 3er
ist dieses jahr das ganze eigentlich
direkt veröffentlichen
also es steht noch nichts zu 1000
millionen dann trilliarden prozent des
ibiza so wird wie sie jetzt hier gerade
vor uns steht und wie wir sie uns heute
im ofen machen werden aber 99,37 9
prozent wie die pizza genau worauf leben
ziemlich unspektakulär wichtiges gezeigt
habt also so wie luca pizza 13 99
prozent aussehen wenn ihr sie aus dem
karton nehmt soja wird sie aussehen
das ist das ist ein laufendes
runtergefallen hat nicht von dir selbst
verloren
di luca pizza 3 wird eine helle soßen
haben sondern die anker käse soße und
dann kommen dort noch fünf weitere geben
sollten drauf also haben wir insgesamt
sechs verschiedene käsesorten auf der lu
kapitza 300 toboll auch zwiebel weil ich
bin locker bedachten das ist gibt dem
ganzen eine schöne grüne farbe und das
hat auch ganz gut angepasst die auf mit
wenig vorgeheizt jetzt sagen weil die
pizza bleiben
aber papier direkt auf den rost auf die
mittlere schiene partner damit die
parteispitze 3
red es ist der käse der hier so hoch und
runter geht übrigens die pfütze das so
groß ist wie oft ein normaler gast das
war eins und zwei auch schon so die man
schaut euch das hier einfach an das hier
sind die pizzen von muster bewusst und
das hier sind normale pizzen im tief
krieg hat also das was sie für den preis
bekommt also das hier ist jetzt die
fertige pizza ich habe es jetzt in vier
gleich große stücke geschnitten am
jugendlich werden gleich probieren ich
muss ganz ehrlich gesagt zugeben ich
habe sie ein bisschen zu lange drin
gelassen
anderthalb minuten zu lang aber ich mag
das auch in der käse hier so ein
bisschen fest ist und apropos geschmack
dünn und nicht werden jetzt zum aller
ersten mal also in münchen haben wir
sondern auch schon probiert von der
pizza aber zum aller ersten mal wie sie
vielleicht wirklich so im laden sein
könnte das papier wert
[Musik]
man kann die schweiz über video nicht
rüberbringen
aber ich kann nicht sagen dass auch die
pizza drauf sein wird also haben ein
komplett nochmal ein pid-verbot und habe
ich halt dieses bianca drauf und dann
halt die fünf käsesorten mozzarella
edamer gouda jetta und emmental und das
grüne hier sind halt noch lauchzwiebeln
ein bisschen für die farbe und
vielleicht selbst halten auch wenn ich
bin begeistert
ich will jetzt nicht objekten so von
wegen was ich möchte mir auf jeden fall
sehr gut schlussendlich muss natürlich
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
ich habe viele kommentare gelesen von
wegen luca hat noch nicht so viel käse
drauf ich muss wirklich sagen es
schmeckt nicht danach als wenn die sechs
sorten käse wald hat folge rot aber wenn
wir jetzt natürlich auch nichts
sehnlicher als so janka brauche so diese
ricotta soße oder wären wir nicht zehn
tonnen und mozzarella und 40 kilogramm
und was weiß ich noch alles offen wir
sind der geringe mengen und von daher
ist jetzt auch nicht so eine übelste
käse explosion aber man merkt auf jeden
fall verschiedene käsesorten und laut
bibel geben dem ganzen einen gewissen
sagen ich mal aber schlussendlich die
bereits gesagt ich kann jetzt lang über
den geschmack reden
schlussendlich muss man selbst probieren
mitte november kommt die pizza raus wir
haben schon etwas genaues sagen werden
überlegt 19
november 2009 10 19 19h aber ich weiß
jetzt dass so fix ist und ja eine pizza
hut umkarton kann ich euch noch nicht so
richtig was sagen
in denen designs drin stecken also
überlegen wie wir das machen die erste
pizza hat die am weißen karton
die zweite hat einen schwarzen jetzt
überlegen wir halten würde geblickt und
ihren lehrer da hingehen sich ja auf
jeden fall noch mal überlegen wie wir
das machen ich werde bisher ist auf
jeden fall noch auch essen und schau mir
dann jetzt die vorstellung des neuen
iphones an war das jetzt gezeigt wird
glaube ich ein iphone wird vorgestellt
daher bietet die hessische verkündete
wir zeigen die chinesen gegen los
spielschluss iphone also bevor ich mir
das neue iphone kaufen würde würde ich
mir selbst über 100 luca pizzen kaufen
neunter noch werden sie aktiv
jetzt haben wir ein neues iphone 11 pro
mit drei kameras vorgestellt und der
frontkamera also vier kameras omas marum
liegt aber im endeffekt niemann nur zum
ende des heutigen blogs kann sich nur
noch eine kurze challenge überlegen
welche zusammenlegen
ok jeder von uns hat jetzt vor sich ein
paar lange socken und ein paar kurze
socken und der die als erstes
zusammenlegt gewinnen 32
er ist auch geschult ich höre heute
bitter ist das hier ja ich wollte zeigen
wie groß meine finger größe hat seinen
kopf
das ist zeigen kannst du dein kopf mache
ich schon hier ist ein foto von mir
damals in der yoga denke mir wirklich
leid leute das ist das jetzt was
funktioniert er weiß bei der purzelbaum
ist fordert der leiharbeit video werden
durch die blogs beinahe wäre jetzt
eigentlich nur noch schlafen und hier
komme ich diese leute haben auf jeden
fall die ersten exemplare der dritt sind
luca pizza bei mir an deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich machen blöcke wie ich
die sachen auspacke wie ich das in ofen
knall wie ich das essen und alles ein
bisschen heute also wir waren ja im gym
und luca pizza 3 kommt auf jeden fall
voraussichtlich am 19 november 2009 10
in alle möglichen supermärkte
infos folgen doch auch wieder karton
aussehen wie et cetera pp es wird auf
jeden fall eine pizza mit einer
ricotta bianca soße und fünf
verschiedenen käsesorten und ob und
lauchzwiebeln und das tool gefallen hat
und schreibt ihr den kommentare nicht
gefallen haben vielleicht ein bisschen
gefahr hier sieht man freundlich
ausgedrückt abonniert main kanal halt
noch ein teil von lukrativen community
und da ist eine glocke da aber nicht
auch dickere unter einem video dass wir
nachhaltig die hochladen
ich will wirklich weg vorbei
[Musik]